for the latest mini election trim I'm
off to North East Somerset to speak to
Jacob Riis smugly known for his unique
public image rich mug won the seat in
2010 after boundary changes but is he at
all concerned about holding on to it and
what kind of election campaign is he
expect about your real action patter in
North East Somerset
well I'm optimistic that the response
when canvassing is positive my campaign
team are very well-organized we've got a
huge amount of literature out and so
we're just waiting for the starting gun
to be fired
the problem with fix our Parliament's is
that it leads to almost perpetual
campaigning we're becoming more American
in this respect one of the things you've
talked about in the past is some kind of
pact with you Kip do you still good you
still believe in that it's too late
we're too close to the election now but
I think a priority for the Conservatives
after the election is to reunite the
conservative family because one of the
things that night Faraj has now said is
that he would do some kind of not a
coalition that's what I'm deal with
David Cameron but it would require an EU
F render before the end of this year
what would you say to that
I think mr. Faraj is a very capable
party leader but if his big objective is
to achieve the United Kingdom leaving
the European Union a referendum by the
end of this year would not be a good way
to achieve that it seems to me that
unless the groundwork is prepared for
what leaving means which has not been
done or there is time for detailed
renegotiation which has not been done
then it is more than likely that the
electorate will remain within the
European Union so in my view a hasty
referendum would be a disaster for euro
scepticism I'm just going back to the
American element about with the current
hot potato in politics is the TV debate
where do you stand on them do you think
the Prime Minister is right to engage in
his political maneuvering to make sure
he doesn't do them it's not the Prime
Minister's political manoeuvring it's
the political manoeuvring of the
broadcaster's who I think they're having
quite disgracefully at wish to take over
our democratic systems that it is surely
for the participants to decide the Prime
Minister made his position clear early
on the broadcaster's failed to sort
things out properly and I think they do
have a political agenda and the director
of strategy at the BBC is a former
labour cabinet minister it seems highly
unlikely that he's not involved in this
decision so there is an element of
politics coming from the broadcasters
and an element of left-wing politics
you're one of the most recognizable
conservative MPs on the bench who
featured very heavily in inside the
Commons and picture that why do you
think it is that you've become so
recognizable well I was told why I
appeared inside the Commons that with
the last thing I did with them they said
to me you're in quite a bit because you
speak in complete sentences and if we
would be very easy to cut and I wasn't
sure whether this was a compliment to my
grammar or wasn't insulted as his hair
cut to fit the press not because you're
sort of a stereotyped Tory anyway do you
think it is I don't think so I'm and I
have them very standard conservative
views I'm very much in the center of the
Conservative Party's philosophy and
finally and I do have to ask there is a
Twitter account at jQuery smug are you
aware of this accountant is this you I
am aware of it it is not me I met the
person who does it I was introduced to
him by Broadcasting House on radio for
couple of years ago one of the reasons I
did tweet personally is that I think the
man who does this is much funnier than I
could hope to be and he does it so well
and rather musingly sometimes what he
says gets created as if I have said it
and some of his aphorisms are so amusing
but I'm rather flattered that they're
attributed to me that's it for this mini
election adventure join me again soon to
find out how the election is being
fought in a different part of the
country find out more at mini election
code
okay